hi there steve coffin here again
and today i'm going to
talk about
whether pitch accent is important in
learning languages like japanese
remember if you enjoy these videos
please subscribe click on the bell for
notifications
so first of all i'm back home all right
i was in palm springs for six weeks
i went there for a variety of reasons
first of all our house needed our house
down there needed some work to be done
on it
uh also we were doing some work here so
it was very messy
drywall dust and so forth so we went
down there and we also got our second
dose of the vaccine
and then
friday night we came back home and i'll
go i'll explain that a little bit
later but pitch accents so there's quite
a debate about
pitch accent particularly in japanese
and i will post a link in the
description box to
a person who speaks flawless japanese
like a japanese person and he is a
proponent of studying pitch accent his
name is dogen
and i will also show you a link to a
video by another person whose name is
casemy who says that
pitch accent is not worth worrying about
and i will leave a third link to a
description of pitch accent from
wikipedia
so
pitch accent is
and it doesn't just exist in japanese
it's the idea that in languages we have
varying intonation
all right intonation
that's not necessarily tied to the
meaning of a word so
in chinese if you say
a chinese word with a wrong tone it's a
different meaning altogether and people
can be
confused or have difficulty
understanding you if you use the wrong
tones that is not the case
in japanese
other uh
languages which according to wikipedia
have this uh pitch accent include
swedish turkish
persian western basque okay just western
basque
uh and i can't remember how ancient
greek
a number of languages that
according to them serbo croatian
have this pitch accent issue
now let me say up front that i lived in
japan for nine years
i spoke japanese japanese and still
deuce quite comfortably i met a lot of
foreigners who spoke japanese very well
no one that i was aware of had ever
heard of pitch accent
so
probably it exists
maybe it's something that some people
want to spend time on
but it is not necessary it is not
necessary
it's not a necessary part of learning
the language of communicating it's
certainly not necessary
insofar as comprehension is concerned
um in chinese on the other hand if you
speak chinese with very bad tones people
may have difficulty understanding you
and in any case it sounds quite bad
it sounds as if you don't speak the
language very well you have to get those
tones up to about 70 80 accuracy
to be taken seriously in japanese that
is not the case
i never pay any attention to pitch
accent i just consider
whatever pitch accent is and i still
don't understand it
it's part of imitating the way people
speak every language has its own
intonation even within japan the
intonation in the kansai and the osaka
area is different from the intonation
in
you know the northeast and the tohoku
area
and the same is true for every language
i mean if you've ever heard of french
canadian and quebecois speak french
their intonation is very different from
the intonation in paris which is
different from the intonation in
southern france
if you've ever heard a swiss person
speak even english very often they'll
have their swiss intonation and i can
only imagine that their
hulk deutsch their standard german also
sounds quite different from the
intonation of a of an austrian or a
bavarian or someone from hamburg so the
idea that there is intonation in a
language i mean we have intonation in
english i i remember when i one of the
reasons why i decided to learn cantonese
was that having learned mandarin with
his four tones and having all these
cantonese people scare you off saying
cantonese is the most difficult language
because it has nine tones and i said
geez i mean i had enough trouble
learning four tones nine tones is just
too difficult but i found this book
written by chinese person anthony
speaker who first of all said you only
need six tones for cantonese and second
of all pointed out that we have tones in
english and you can hear me hear me in
my english i also have tones
so
is it worthwhile
you know going into great detail
classifying i mean persian is described
or turkish as a tonal language i just
listen to it and try to imitate it
um
i think i do okay i don't have enough
vocabulary in those languages to speak
them well but it's not my lack of
emphasis on pitch accent that's holding
me back
by the way just to digress so my wife
and i
head back home to canada
some trepidation about what's going to
happen at the border because actually
the government heavily discourages you
from traveling
outside the country and if you fly into
a major airport you have to quarantine
in a hotel that the government dictates
and you pay for it
while waiting for your first test
results to come back could be two or
three days
we didn't want to do that so we flew
from palm springs to bellingham which is
20 minutes from the border
the luggage took a while to come out so
it was getting later and later we had
trouble getting an uber we couldn't get
an uber we finally got a lyft
driver to come to the airport he drove
us to the border now it's dark it's
close to 10 o'clock we're dropped off at
the peace arch park we don't know where
to go we wander around in the park
finally found a sort of a sidewalk
followed it got to a road
walked for about a mile pulling my
luggage until we got to the border and
there there's a very serious looking
sign there with a big stop sign stop
until you are motioned forward by an
agent okay stop so we waited and waited
and waited cars every so often a car
would come back and the customs official
would come along customs official would
deal with the car i thought are they
ever going to pay attention to us so
finally they came
and
basically i had registered on a
government
app or downloaded an app so i had
already sent them ahead all our
information
so the it went very very smoothly they
knew who we were
uh asked us a few questions and then
told us that we would have to quarantine
for 14 days and that the penalty for
breaking quarantine could be as high as
a million dollars or three years in jail
i don't think they'd ever do that but
that's kind of to scare you right
and then they said you're lucky because
the
self-testing tent hasn't closed yet so
go off to the tent there and the nurse
there will show you how to self-test
because we're gonna have to self-test
again in seven days so we might have had
and there were two or three different
nurses that couldn't have been
kinder more helpful more pleasant took
us through our paces registered us on a
website where we have to report then our
second test
did the test in our nostrils one you
know 15 seconds in each nostril put it
in this little container send it off
we're gonna have to do the same seven
days later
then we went out
to find an uber
i walked a ways and then called the uber
our uber driver got lost
ended up actually having i think he went
across in the united states he then told
us that
the uh
border guards there told him that uh you
know he had to prove that he was an uber
driver so he wouldn't have to quarantine
on his way back anyway he was an afghan
immigrant so i was able to speak some
farsi with him in the car
i have no idea
what pitch accent he had and i think it
makes no difference
i just a brief aside i think that the
only way we're getting through this
uh covent epidemic is through vaccines
anybody who is not willing to get a
vaccine is simply a part of the problem
not a part of the solution and the same
was true with masking before we were
vaccinated that was the only way we
could keep a lid on the pandemic i just
don't understand people who in the name
of some kind of freedom refuse to
cooperate with everybody else in trying
to basically
help the whole of society get through
this thing anyway that's as i said i
have the freedom to drive through a red
light it's the same idea
anyway getting back to pitch accent so
i think all these languages apparently
have pitch accent i think there is a
great tendency it's fine for linguists
academic linguists to study different
qualities of languages and categorize
them and this is subject verb object and
this is
subject object verb and this belongs to
this other group and
it doesn't matter for the language
learner we simply have to imitate what
we hear we have to get used to the
pattern of the language and um
in my swedish there are tones in swedish
i like to imitate
you imitate it the same is true in
japanese and if i spend a lot of time
with people from osaka
uh i end up with more of an osaka accent
um it doesn't affect the meaning it's
not like chinese tones
but it's something that again you know
you talk about
tones that compare
compare a brazilian to someone from
portugal different areas different
people even native speakers are going to
have different
types of intonation and you will
naturally want to imitate
the accent and the intonation
that that either you like the best or
that is more useful for you in your work
or you consider more prestigious or
whatever it might be
and i don't think
and the other thing about pitch accent
is it is possible that if i put a lot of
effort on pitch accent so i decided i'm
not going to be i'm not going to allow
myself to be influenced by having spent
two evenings with people from osaka
which inevitably makes me speak with
more of an osaka accent i'm going to try
to
you know nail down
the the sort of pitch accent of a
japanese national broadcast announcer
nhk announcer so i'm going to go whole
hog with the dogen program
uh
and but the problem is that language is
about communication it's not a
performance sport no one i'm not i don't
care if people tell me well you're a
japanese pronunciation sounds a bit this
way that way i don't care
uh people are comfortable communicating
with me
i'm comfortable because i understand
what people are saying to me in japanese
i'm not seeking perfection
uh you know it's it's not a performance
it's it's communication and to that
extent people who do want to achieve the
nhk announcers uh intonation
by all means
but to pretend that this is important
uh
it's not as important as increasing your
vocabulary it's not as important as
having a good command
of the language and using words
appropriately using words that belong
together being able to express your
thoughts clearly that's far more
important
than pursuing the ultimate you know in
tones i had i mentioned this before i
had a swiss banker who came in with this
sidekick from england
to try and sell something to us the
swiss banker had a strong swiss accent
in his english but he used words so well
he expressed himself so accurately so
elegantly
and his english sidekick
maybe he wasn't that well educated he
didn't use the english language as well
but he spoke with a native accent so
if you want to pursue pitch accent by
all means do so but in my opinion it's
not that important and i certainly pay
no attention to it anyway
uh and i'm gonna leave a couple of
videos here to follow up on the subject
of pronunciation and seeking to be
perfect and so forth so thank you for
listening bye for now